in 2011 scientists created
glow-in-the-dark cats the researchers
took a gene
from glowing jellyfish and inserted it
into the unfertilized eggs of house cats
it was a neat trick
but they had a bigger goal in mind
they also made the cats more likely to
be resistant to a
feline form of aids by again
manipulating their dna and cats
aren't that different than humans in
fact
we share around 90 percent of our dna
with them
so why can't we engineer humans in the
same way
well we can engineer ourselves to be
resistant to life-threatening
illnesses that is in fact
one scientist claims that he's
genetically engineered
two babies using a revolutionary tool
called crispr but what exactly is a
crispr baby anyway
would you like to be six feet tall or
never bald
the secret to traits like these lies in
the six
billion letters of your genetic code
but there can be something else in there
as well
mutations genetic mutations are
linked to at least 6 000 medical
conditions
from sickle cell anemia to huntington's
disease
but what if you could make those
mutations
simply disappear that's where the
gene editing tool crispr comes in
crispr is made from specialized proteins
and other compounds found in certain
bacteria
normally these proteins protect the
bacteria
by destroying enemy invaders like
viruses
but the inventors of crispr figured out
how to turn those proteins against
genetic mutations
and other genes linked to disease
first they give the proteins coordinates
of the wanted gene
then crispr runs a seek and destroy
function
after that other molecules are
dispatched to repair the gene with new
healthy dna and just like that
you can edit the human genome but while
the edits may be quick
their changes can last for centuries
especially if you're editing the dna in
an embryo
embryos start out with a single cell
that eventually replicates into millions
and then trillions more so
if you alter that initial cell first
you're manipulating the ingredients for
every cell that follows
later in life and those same altered
cells can be passed on
from generation to generation that's one
reason
why most experiments on human embryos
haven't left the lab
that is except for the work of dr
john kwai he claims to have used crispr
to target and knock out the ccr5 gene in
human embryos
which is linked to hiv infection
and then he did something that shocked
the scientific community
he implanted the embryos into several
women
one of whom gave birth to genetically
modified twins
resistance to hiv aside most scientists
say
the procedure was too risky at least two
studies suggest
that edited cells might actually trigger
cancer
and another found that crispr can
accidentally take
aim at healthy dna so while crispr could
make us
immune to disease who knows what else we
might get on the side